coming up tonight on nbcsn is ring city
boxing at 9 eastern time bob papa who
i've gotten to know very well he did
thursday football for many years he's an
outstanding broadcaster he'll be
ringside
alongside the analyst for ring-sitting
boxing at 9 eastern time on nbc
sn it's our two-time welterweight
champion friend sean porter how are you
sir how you been
i'm doing i'm doing great how are you
rich you know when you were here
talking to me i thought this guy could
should get into television
and you're doing that aren't you sean
you're doing that i i actually
am and i'm extremely blessed uh now i'm
with nbc
but also uh doing things with fox as
well so
it's good everything is fun you know
fantastic i'm glad that you're
you're now multi you're multi-channel uh
right now sean
so let's get let's get into this right
what is tonight set the table for
tonight give me give me the table for
you
i'm i'm sorry go ahead go set the table
go for it sean oh you want me to set
this yes
i thought you were gonna do that no
you're i'm not ringside with bob papa
you are
i haven't been trained to set the table
yet but i'll do the best i can
listen ring city boxing is coming to nbc
sport
it's on tonight 9 p.m eastern standard
time
and you're going to see some great
action styles make fights and that's
what what tonight is all about i think
we got three tv fights
and the styles are our action-packed and
i think uh everyone who tunes in is
going to be
uh very excited and grateful uh for what
nbc is
going to bring into this to the sport of
boxing well who do you who
who are you excited to see fight tonight
who should i be tuning in to see fight
tonight
sean the main event you got but listen
to this you got
mickey romain who's got like 72 uh
professional matches
uh where i i would i wouldn't even dream
to have that many fights
and he's still going strong and he's
going up against a shocky foster
who's a young kid out of uh houston
texas
and both guys are strong both guys are
fast it's gonna be action-packed that's
the fight of the night that's the main
event
okay that's again at nine eastern time
on nbcsn tonight um there's a big
pay-per-view fight coming up on december
5th
errol spence jr and danny garcia trying
to unify the welterweight belt that's
going to be in front of fans actually in
the jones mahal in dallas you fought
both of these guys
how do you think this is going to go
down you know what i think there's a lot
of
different avenues this fight could take
i think uh it all depends on two things
number one
is is arrow spent still aerospace after
his horrific
accident and then number two is is danny
garcia prepared to tell
aerosmith junior that he is not who he
used to be
you know i think that danny's got to
come out and let his hands fly
and i think that aerospring junior has
got to
remain calm and understand that this is
his home
inside of the ring and and this is what
he loves to do
and so i think it's gonna be a great
fight and uh
and i i really don't know who's gonna
win the fight right now i i
like i said i'm gonna put a tweet out
about uh right after the first
round letting everyone know who i think
is going to win the fight i think the
first round
is to tell tale for us in that fight so
uh
and then deontay wilder you already had
to say monday about tyson fury did you
hear about that sean
i i've been seeing over the course of
the last few weeks but i did not see
what he had to say
he said that his fury flat out was
cheating and that you know that fury had
weight in his weights and his gloves and
now he's claiming his water respect
about that one he's kind of been on he's
been
on a little bit of a rant now for a
couple of weeks and
i think the worst part about it is it's
coming too late i think if he wanted to
make these accusations they should have
come right after the fight
where everything was fresh and new and
everyone could have really dug into this
whole matter and really figured it out i
think now even though
he's put out some evidence i think some
of the evidence is substantial but at
the same time
it's so far away from the match is what
what how much of a uh
how much can you really uh detect
and and and and and really figure out
what was really going on that night
it's a sad thing right now for him no i
know has your have you ever had spiked
water sean
before five years i've i've never had a
spiked
anything uh know what i want to okay
i don't spike anything myself well you
like spiking your opponent that's for
sure
so who do you want about it who do you
want to fight next what about you
um you know i'm i'm actually mandatory
for every belt that's out there
every belt that's been created for
boxing i'm mandatory to fight so
i'm mandatory to fight kenneth crawford
right now for his wbo title and i'm also
mandatory to fight
the winner of danny garcia and else jr
so
uh for me it's just a matter of who
wants me
okay and bob arum said he doesn't make
any money on crawford's recent fights
what would you do if you were crawford
hearing that i i i would have a serious
conversation with with bob and let him
know that that cannot be said again
and and if so my loyalty does not lie
with you anymore
and i'm gonna go where where i can make
all the money that i can make you know
so
uh there's there's some room over here
with pvc it's just a matter of
of uh chance crawford wanted to make
that move that change
all right well big big one tonight how
are you prepping for tonight
sean big one tonight man i got my laptop
right here in front of me i got
i got a uh i got a briefcase right here
in front of me man i'm i'm locked and
loaded and i'm excited to uh
bring boxing to nbc i hope everyone
tunes in
nbc is bringing something special and
something new to the to the sport that i
don't think
has necessarily been done definitely not
recently so i hope everyone tunes in to
nbc sports tonight at uh eight at six
p.m
uh pacific time okay so uh are you gonna
do
do you need like maybe freddie roach
giving you some sort of tips beforehand
and get you going like you used to back
in the day i mean what
do you got what do you think i'm i'm
good because i'm not wrapping up tonight
but i'm sure if i was wrapping up i'd
definitely be looking at freddie i know
that all the fighters out here
they're excited to be fighting here at
the wild card and they're excited to be
performing in front of freddie so i'm
sure freddie will treat them just like
he treated me and give them the best
information that he can uh at this point
in time how did he treat you
give me good freddie roach story sean i
i gave you the best freddie rose story
so after i did my my uh training camp in
2010
with manny pacquiao he fought miguel
cotto freddie and i was just standing
around we're talking and he says you're
going to be a champion someday
and i just in my head i was thinking
yeah he says that to all the young guys
whatever and and i and i said even
though i felt that way i said you know
what i'm going to win this championship
and i'm going to bring it back and show
freddie and sure enough a few years
later
i won the ibf title i brought it back to
the wild card
and i was i was full of smiles looking
at freddy
and he just looked at me says i i told
you you were gonna do it and
and like just gave my heart the most
exciting butterflies ever because and
then i was like wow he actually
remembers saying that to me this is
amazing so
freddy's an awesome guy that's pretty
cool well but i also know the feeling of
when somebody says something you're
saying they're
you're just saying that to be nice like
when you were here the last time
and uh my sound engineer audio executive
mike deltufa said sean would definitely
know who i am and you said absolutely i
know who i am
and then uh and then you actually
apparently didn't know who mike deltufo
is
yeah yeah yeah i he was setting up
things
at the fight or whatever and then and
then i saw him again
right there at the studio so um yeah i
remember a lot i also remember that you
are a
jets fan yes it's true they are
crumbling and continuing to crumble
well you know i i you know i i will
accept that
sean because they are 0-9 um
but the one thing is if i'm not mistaken
um
you are a fan of which team sean i
yeah i'm a fan of the browns yeah so
that's so i don't i don't know if i'm
willing to accept
that from you is what i'm saying well
i'm
i'm just offering some advice and some
comfort if you need
as as a as i've been there and and i've
been there year and year
after year yes uh we're doing very well
right now
uh so you know i'm just here to comfort
you that's all rich
i don't hear the confidence no i
appreciate that sean i appreciate that
um i you know how old are you i think
i'm twice your age how old are you sean
i'm 33. okay 33. so i'm not twice your
age not exactly but i'm a hard shell of
a 51 year old man that's been hollowed
out inside of 50 years of jet fandom
so um i i just i just don't know if i
need to accept this from a browns fan
uh who's it who's it sick what uh six
and three right now right feeling good
about yourself
we're sitting at six and three and after
all those points
okay and we still may not make the
playoffs i feel like i'm sparring with
sean porter right now
you don't want to do that right so i
will then say goodbye uh
thanks for the call sean have a good
time tonight with bob papa on nbcs thank
you
you got it that is none other than
showtime sean p
as he's known on twitter and instagram
sean porter will be part
again ringside with bob pops on bob papa
on the debut of ring city boxing tonight
at nine eastern time on on nbcsn